good morning believe nation today's
message is leverage creates wealth over
to you Steve see bold I think we're all
taught that we all we trade hours for
dollars we're taught and I don't know
about you but I was taught in high
school in college all throughout my
academic career that hard work equals
success and the wealthy laugh at that I
mean they know hard work really doesn't
unless you're talking about hard work in
terms of thinking hard work really can
get you I mean my dad was a bricklayer
here in Chicago most of his life and he
worked really hard he made a good living
but certainly it was never wealthy
because hard work typically doesn't hard
physical work especially doesn't equate
to wealth leverage creates wealth and
how do which people use leverage and how
do they use their thought process to get
rich well they leverage everything it's
one of the greatest lessons I ever
learned from the wealthy in the last 26
years of interviews they leveraged their
education their contacts their knowledge
their money they leveraged everything to
help them build greater wealth I don't
think that I agree with the tenant that
hard work doesn't create wealth I think
if you look at the wealthiest people who
built it not inherited their wealth they
work insanely hard but I do agree that
leverage does create wealth and leverage
creates opportunities and leverage lets
you do the things that your best in the
world that I think too many
entrepreneurs try to do everything
themselves and and don't realize that
there are easy ways to get people to
help you and it doesn't have to cost you
a lot of money right a lot of people
think oh I need to go out and spend 40 K
to hire somebody to help me and I don't
have that kind of money I'm not even
making that kind of money yet it's one
you can hire people part-time it's two
if you are standing for something
important have a powerful mission you
can get people on board who want to join
you because they love what you're all
about it's three tapping into the
connections and resources and people in
your family and community and friends
and neighbors and see if they can lend
some assistance at the start it's just
getting out of the mindset that you have
to do everything yourself as long as you
try to do every single thing yourself in
the business one you'll never get to
where you want to go
because you're doing a bunch of stuff
that you're not good at I have no
intention to be good at but you just
kind of grind your way through it
but if you're only spending 10 percent
of your time doing the things you can
great at how can you build something
great how can you build that great
company and so as soon you can get into
that mindset if I need to build a team I
need to have people around me to support
what I'm weak at that's when you start
to create real leverage and build
something that matters so the question
is a today is I'm curious how big your
team is are you a solo entrepreneur do
you have people on your team are you
looking at expanding and hiring what's
your thought process around there right
now leave it in the comments below I'm
gonna join the discussion thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press